sa mort avait exacerbé les tensions
entre états unis et iran la république
islamique en hommage au général qasem
soleimani assassiné le 3 janvier 2020
son convoi avait été la cible d'un drone
américain près de l'aéroport de bagdad
suite à ce meurtre l'iran avait riposté
en ciblant des bases américaines en irak
aujourd'hui encore sa disparition
suscite un sentiment de vengeance de la
part du chef de l'autorité judiciaire
iranienne
ne pensez pas que quelqu'un comme le
président des états unis qui apparaît
comme un assassin ou qui a ordonné un
assassinat peut s'en tirer et se sentir
protégés de la loi et de la justice et
se sentir en sécurité
jamais ceux qui ont joué un rôle dans ce
meurtre ne seront nulle part en sécurité
sur cette terre déjà considéré comme une
légende de son vivant
le chef de la force al qods l'unité
d'élite des gardiens de la révolution
islamique
et depuis son décès élevés au rang de
martyrs par tout un peuple
apprécié pour son calme et sa proximité
avec ses soldats kouassem soleymani a
ouvré pour renforcer l'influencé
iranienne dans la région notamment en
irak
ce dimanche c'est d'ailleurs dans la
capitale irakienne que les tensions
américano iranienne risque de se faire
ressentir
l'ambassade américaine à bagdad déjà
ciblé après la mort du général craint de
nouvelles attaques
pas plus tard qu'il ya deux semaines une
salve de roquettes a explosé près du
bâtiment sans avoir été revendiqué
l'ambassade qui a également annoncé
avoir fourni 30 véhicules blindés à
l'armée irakienne
pour se prémunir d'éventuelles
représailles